-My next guest
is a very talented comedian
who hosts a weekly podcast
called "Don't Ask Tig."
Please welcome Tig Notaro!
-[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey. Ahh! Tig! [ Laughs ]
Look at us! Look at us now.
Look at this.
-Look at us.
-It's incredible.
-Unbelievable.
Unbelievable. Incredible.
Thank you so much
for coming back to the show.
I want to talk to you
about something because
now you're an action star,
and so I feel like --
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, you are.
You're in Zack Snyder's
"Army of the Dead" movie.
And we talked about that.
-Yeah.
-They just released the trailer.
-Mm-hmm.
-And all anyone
was talking about
is how much they love Tig Notaro
and how Tig Notaro is sexy A.F.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
Did you -- Look --
This photo -- Look at this.
Yeah!
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-The crowd loves it!
What is -- What is --
What has -- What has
life been like for
this past week being sexy A.F.?
-Oh, my gosh. So much
has changed, Jimmy, since --
[ Laughter ]
It's -- It's really been nuts
around here
since I was trending
for being sexy A.F.
-That's right. That's right.
-I didn't even know
what "A.F." was, to be honest.
My friends were texting me
images of Twitter.
They were like, "You're --
You're trending for
being badass and sexy A.F."
And I was like, "What is that?"
-[ Laughs ]
Dude, I was so happy for you.
That was fun. That's cool.
How is the family?
How are the kids?
How's your wife?
How's everybody?
-Everybody's good. Yeah.
You know, we're --
-What are they into?
-Well, my wife is into me
now that I'm sexy A.F.
-"All right.
We got it. We got it.
All right. Jesus."
[ Laughs ]
-And, you know, it puts a little
fire under her, you know,
for me to be trending
for sexy A.F., but --
-Yeah, we heard
the first four times, yeah.
-Right, but it's
gonna come up again.
Trust me.
My -- My sons
are really into baseball.
They are crazy about it.
My -- They --
They play all day long.
Just throwing the ball,
hittin' -- hittin' the ball.
You know, baseball stuff.
Catching the ball.
-Yeah, that's --
-Runnin'.
-That's basically baseball.
Yeah, absolutely.
-Yeah.
And I just --
I watch on sexy A.F., of course.
-Oh, my g-- That's not --
-We -- We signed them up
for Little League and --
-How old are they?
-Yeah, well, they're --
they're almost 5.
I don't know if it's
Little League, actually.
I know I look like
I should know these things,
but it's just T-ball.
They're in T-ball.
Is that Little League?
I don't know.
-No. But -- Yeah, yeah.
-It's -- It's a league.
-That's great, though.
That's young to --
to start, isn't it?
That's amazing.
-Yeah. And they're really good.
They both, first day, hittin'
the ball out to centerfield.
And -- And all the kids
are great, but to be honest,
it was a little amusing
because the two gay moms
showed up with the star players.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's hilarious.
Yeah, why not?
I think it's great.
-"Why not" is exactly our point.
A lot of, like,
you know, buff dads,
and their sons couldn't quite
make contact with the ball
to the bat.
And we were like, "Yeah!" with
our -- with our little ones.
-Rooting against children.
Tig, I was listening
to your podcast.
-Always.
-"Don't Ask Tig."
And it was the one --
It was the episode --
First of all, I love it.
Basically, you take
questions from fans,
and you and a special guest
give your advice
on answering those questions,
and it's really funny,
and I love it, but --
-No, I know, I know.
I know how the show goes.
-Oh, sorry.
No. I was talking to them.
Sorry. Yeah.
-Oh, oh, okay. Okay.
-But you recently
had Paula Poundstone on.
And as you were talking
to Paula --
-Yeah.
-Gosh, I love Paula Poundstone.
As you're talking on her,
you -- your -- your --
one of your boys
starts yelling for you.
And -- And --
-Yeah.
He was stuck
on the bathroom counter.
-So, what happened? He climbed
up there and then got nervous?
-I have no idea what happened.
Look, he's a great
baseball player.
-I know. We heard that.
I know he is, yeah.
-He got a little --
He got a little nervous
on the bathroom counter.
I don't know.
I didn't have time, you know?
I had Paula Poundstone
on my show, and, uh...
-Who has time to raise
their kids? Exactly right.
-Yeah. I ran downstairs,
grabbed him off the counter.
I was like, "Don't get
on the bathroom counter!"
And then ran back up,
and, you know,
did my global-hit sensation
of a podcast, "Don't Ask Tig."
-Yeah. I want to talk about --
You also have another movie out
called "Together Together."
-Yes.
-This is with Ed Helms
and Patti Harrison,
where you play a therapist.
And I was like,
"Oh, it makes sense."
You did a little research
to be a therapist.
That's what got the pod--
Which came first --
the podcast or the egg?
You know what I'm saying?
-No, there was
no research, Jimmy.
People -- Now that I've --
I've gotten into acting
over the past few years,
people always ask
how I prepare for roles,
and if I'm completely honest,
I don't.
My preparation
is I learn my lines
to the best of my ability.
-Well, when you show up
and you do something like this,
you don't need any lines.
Boom!
-Sexy A.F.
-Tig, congrats on everything.
Congrats on the movies.
Congrats on the podcast.
We love you.
And please come back whenever,
next time hopefully in person.
Tig Notaro.
-Thank you.
-Check out new episodes
of her podcast, "Don't Ask Tig,"
every Wednesday.